morning my boy morning brother breakfast
time heads up Chef
J guess we're just haven't leftover
P it's a adventure comedy movie uh sorry
can I take that again I I
mean like all of it is pretty odd we
kind of wrote it just being like surely
will'll have to cut a lot of
this
oh my God your boy's okay let's go it is
about three best friends who set out to
find treasure hoping that will solve all
their problems and it either does or
doesn't it's like Indiana Jones but
nothing like Indiana Jones 100 Mil $100
million I mean I know it's more than
this but at least a million each
significantly more so it's this kind of
silly look at what it means to grow up
all three of them were born in uh
2018 so these are very young kids and
the script is ambitious you're three
hours late dad you don't understand the
subs was busted so we had to shred you
had to shred this is kind of a
autobiographical story um we all met and
uh we went to a mountain and we found
treasure we started developing the
script before they got Saturday Night
Live and then they got Saturday Night
Live and then suddenly they they were
really breaking out quickly and we
thought we had to do it when I met Jud
and started talking to him with the guys
it just happened very fast he was really
behind it he really believed in it Jud
would say to me is like I'm having Deja
Vu those guys are how he and Sandler
were in their crew you know 30 years ago
more of a fan of the blanket
myself that's
disgusting that was such a clean pop in
sixth grade we had to do a project on
hero
like in the world like people chose like
Martin Luther King Jr and I chose
Jud and my teacher was like who like
like what who is this and to be working
with him it's truly amazing it's almost
like a flashback when I was working with
my knucklehead friends you on Happy
Gilmore sets and then they introduced us
to all sorts of really funny people that
are in their comic World they half
bad hey oh my god oh d you guys want a
drink or should I go myself a drink
yeah let do a drink let's do a drink am
I doing my line too
sexy sometimes you're forgetting that
we're not just like in high school doing
a play and like having fun the script is
so funny that it feels really big but I
think when you're with your friends it
feels like oh we're just like hanging
out and having the best time and it
doesn't feel like work at all John been
in Mar and you can't deny it they're so
funny and they work so hard they have
not had a day off since top of the year
with SNL and then writing this man we
have so much fun around here man it's
like a so kind um I really hate
them
okay I apologize for
him oh my
God the dial just turns up the entire
time every scene is like one more Notch
of
intensity sorry okay okay got we got
really lucky with like being able to do
most of the stuff that we wanted to
do Wing suits Wing suiting through the
sky oh my
God you're like a kite what you're like
my kite almost every scene has some
element of like I can't believe that
this is actually being shot oh my God
got us here maybe we could have wrote a
version of it that was happening on the
ground you live and you learn I did
seriously bruise my
making a
movie making a movie
today I'm an active hater of please
don't destroy I've been trying to
destroy them for years how dare you
interrupt our sacred dance okay we need
to punch some hes in this thing
I think they've done a really good job
of ratcheting that up to something so
funny and absurd it's just a comedy
that's firing on a lot of cylinders done
it
Lisa I really like their work a lot they
really make me laugh so when they told
me this was possible I thought well
that'd be cool because this thing well
UPS my Sexual Energy and magnetism by
70% the Friendship is real it's
authentic they have this thing that you
just want to root for them we don't hang
out outside of it I was just tell this
is a professional relation right right
right right yeah yeah absolutely yeah
there's kind of a magic that they have
when they are together I don't really
speak to Martin and John anymore you
feel it in every frame uh that you know
these guys love each other and how tight
they are and that they really make each
other laugh you've been fighting and
honestly I think that this could be the
end of our relationship as we dug deeper
into our friendship the more that we
could write better jokes is a movie
about guys who work and live together
and love each other and that is our life
it's what I've wanted to do my whole
life and to be able to do it with my two
best friends is really
cool Mountain Compass treasure friends
Mountain compass compass friends friends
treasure treasure friends Mountain
Compass oh my God it's an
animal what was
[Music]
that